Clinton is with us in Indiana hi Clinton
how are you oh just fine thank you -
enjoy your show thank you
how can I help my question to you is a
past show I had hurt you and you had
talked about like putting a thousand
1,500 back a month and in a period over
a course of like 15 years you said it
would turn over to about five million
was i hearing it right or hearing it
wrong no no I can put it in let's just
put it in thousand dollars a month I'll
stick in the calculator right now and
starting with nothing and let's just use
a twelve percent if you made twelve
percent of your mutual funds which I do
some people gripe at me about that but
that's what I use and let's see you said
fifteen years yes okay
let's just use that well just see what
that comes out that comes out to be a
half million okay in 15 years
so fifteen hundred would be do that
again make sure I did that right but we
said a thousand dollars a month right
this industry in fifteen years it comes
out to be a half million you know if we
want a million you'd have to do double
that you have to do two thousand if you
wanted to do it in 15 years let's see
what twenty years comes up just for the
fun of it and that twenty years comes
out nine hundred eighty-nine thousand so
close to me and so you've been meeting
there in about 20 years about a thousand
dollars a month give or take I mean that
depends on the rate of return that your
mutual funds yield but that's using a
12% example and again if you want to
find a bunch of pissed-off people just
type in Dave Ramsey twelve percent in
Google and you'll find everybody the
world pissed off at me about that but
all right yeah they're all think I'm
crazy but I don't know why I'm crazy
I've been able to do it and it's really
not rocket science but on you know my
mutual funds have averaged in excess of
that but some people can't seem to pull
that off especially in the financial
world but if you want to use a more
conservative rate when you're figuring
it out use a more conservative rate but
the point is that to get to saving and
the point is if you start investing
systematically you know a thousand
fifteen hundred bucks a month and
fifteen to twenty years you're going to
have some serious money that's what it
comes down to
good question thank you for joining us
by the way if you guys ever want to do
you know calculations for your
retirement and I'll just jump on Chris
Hogan's website there's a free
calculator on there a few free process
on there called the our IQ is websites
Chris Hogan 360 dot-com and he's got the
our IQ the retire inspired quotient the
retirement what your retirement IQ is
and it will help you walk through
exactly what you need to be saving are
you doing enough have you done too much
are you on track everybody's always want
to know what their number is well you
need to know what your retirement number
is and so you need to increase your
retirement IQ that's what it comes down
to hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
Oh